keeping it real real how we keep it get
ready for Eddie
back greetings of Peace welcome to the
dean show you hear the term Islam
radical Islam Muslim terrorist so I
brought someone who doesn't only look
like a Muslim but he's a Muslim to
answer this
question with youum how are you doing
alhamdulillah I'm fine president from
the irf yeah let's get let's get right
into it have you term this term is being
thrown around constantly right it took
this beautiful word subm ISL submission
to the will of the Creator true Islam
summed up in one word Islam to acquire
peace by doing what Jesus did Moses did
Abraham and all the messengers of God
submit your will entirely to the creator
of the heavens and earth and that's how
you get peace from owner peace something
with one word Islam can you put radical
in front of Islam it's very absur to do
that because you already defined what is
Islam Islam means peace or submitting in
peace now to say radical Islam is like
saying radical peace and that sounds
it's just very absur to use those words
yeah that so that's like saying radical
peace how could it be radical peace
absolutely yeah so we take just the same
way would you say we don't say radical
Christianity yes of course we shouldn't
I mean to to put Christianity into the
frame of radicalism is not just because
Christians some of them even if a
majority of them do something wrong
suppose if 95% of Christians become
radicals still you cannot call it
radical Christianity because all the 95%
hypothetically can be wrong practicing
wrong Christianity so I mean a religion
is to be judged by the scripture a
religion is to be judged by the person
who introduced the scripture so if I
want to understand Christianity I would
look at Jesus Christ my peace be upon
him his life his teachings the same way
I would do with Moses my peace PE be
upon him and the same way it has to be
done with Prophet Muhammad may peace be
upon him and if someone is to quote out
of context you can do it from everywhere
you can do it from the religious
Scholars from the scripture you can do
it from the Constitutions of the world
you can do it from the leaders and their
speeches when they give it an interest
of nationalism for National Security and
you can just pick up a statement out of
context to say that this guy is a
radical this guy is an extremist this
guy is a terrorist and without a second
thought there may be so many out of
context
quotes that can be picked up to prove
that Trump is a terrorist and I don't
think that's right to do that's not
right to do now you you see this
happening you see such a beautiful way
of life you know this whole concept this
whole religion and I said look I I have
someone who not only looks like a Muslim
is a Muslim and how I mean a Muslim
doesn't necessar look like to praise be
to God yeah a Muslim is simply one who
submits to the will of God so he could
be Chinese you're actually from where
are you from I from India hiad yeah but
not all Muslims are from from India
right yeah absolutely yeah same thing
you're looking at myself here um so we
have um yourself myself Muslim and I'm
saying come to the Muslims to learn
about Islam what people are propagating
some people there are a lot of great
people out there who see past this they
see past you know the smoke screen this
this um nonsense that's been put out
there but what people are trying
to propagate some many of the haters
because islamophobia is a quarter of a
million plus annual business people are
making money throwing dirt on Islam know
so what do you say when people are
saying no no Islam is what actually
makes people turns people into you know
there's this there's this version of
Islam this part of Islam that makes
people radical what do you have to say
to
that basically uh Ed if you have heard
about a report that was published in
Times magazine that was in 16th April
1979 and the report it said that 60,000
books were written against
Islam and what was the time period from
the time period 1,800 to
1950 so it's like beginning 19th century
till the mid of 20th century now if you
just calculate that it would mean 60,000
6 60,000 books that would mean more than
one book was published against Islam per
day in that period of 150 years and
where was it published it was mostly
published in the Western Community so
unfortunately the innocent people of the
Western World the common population the
common citizen the lay man here when he
learned Islam he learned it through
these books so not that islamophobia is
a reaction to the dishonest propaganda
that was done through these books to
defame Islam to Mel Islam because the
think tanks of the time these literature
writers they knew that if there can be
any challenge to their stupid behavior
in the Society of fooling the masses
enslaving them
economically again bringing them back as
their own slaves to do what they wish to
do of a very unjust capitalist economy
the only challenge could be Islam so
before Islam could reach through
scriptures before Muslims could
represent Islam in this beautiful world
they made sure that the masses here are
already ignorant about Islam or have a
wrong judgment about Islam and that is
how you find the islamophobia growing
here and that's not stopping there are
so many other books still
written let's go to this clip there's a
gentleman who's out there and he seems
to be like a
self-proclaimed scholar of Islam an
expert of Islam and we're going to see
what you have to say let's go to this
clip I am not a Muslim I'm not any
religion at all but it bothered me when
you were talking about Islam being not a
religion of Peace
um Muhammad was a very peaceful man no
he wasn't yes he well he yes and he had
a great respect for women his wife
were um given a great deal of power over
him and have you been reading Karen
Armstrong is that where where from no
I've read he's not he was a conquering
warlord who spread the Faith with the
sword quite successfully so as you can
see he's uh the woman who's she doesn't
seem like she belongs to any religion
but she's saying that Prophet Muhammad
was a peaceful man and then he questions
what did you listen to Karen Armstrong
who's an academic you know well
researched historian and there's there's
a great uh that's a great reference
point also for someone who wants to to
know more of the history and it looks
like she did her homework but then he
talks about you know uh the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him being a a
warlord and what how would you respond
to him see basically as far as this guy
is concerned I'm very sure he has ever
tried to read the Quran or the history
of Islam from the right sour our es and
I don't know I mean listening to him
it's nothing new that I'm listening
being in this field we have been
listening a lot of Debaters a lot of
critics of Islam cynics of Islam a lot
of anti-islamic politicians uh running
their show or running their business and
in our time the easiest way to become
popular is speak against Islam and
Muslims and you have the whole media
begging you for that MH unfortunately
the mainstream media not the whole media
because this itself didn't show is a
media source so I would not blame whole
media but still the mainstream media
generally backs the person who speaks
against Islam very easily so this guy is
getting that publicity that's what I
feel and I'm very sure he has not sat
down properly with real uh type Muslims
that who should counter him in the right
perspective and as far as Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
radicalizing or something is concerned
you know I mean the great people in the
line of Karen Armstrong in our
contemporary times you look at Bernard
Shaw you look at Gandhi who was our
freedom national hero that's a good
point Gandhi gandh yeah yeah in the
young India back in 1920 he says that
it's very abser to believe that Islam
was spread by sword he starts praising
Prophet Muhammad for his characters for
his morals and he says the way he had
devoted his life towards his people and
his self-sacrifice his striving towards
his goal and his mission without a
compromise and the way the people around
him they devoted themselves to him so
Gandhi g he says this was the main power
of Islam and not the sword at all you
look at Thomas carile in his book Heroes
and hero worship I mean these are
historians who have studied history this
guy I'm very sure what history has he
studied once he says I'm an atheist
somewhere he goes on to support Jesus
and now he's being a bigotry I mean on
one side he's talking about Prophet
Muhammad he doesn't understand that
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam when he came how many wars did
he participate in how many people did he
kill by his sword he doesn't even know
that historically the sword of Muhammad
wasallam it killed only one enemy can
you imagine that how many was did he
participated how many people were killed
a lot of wars that took place at the
time of prophet Muhammad have a
background to it yeah and those
backgrounds I'm very sure this guy has
never studied talk talk real before we
go to break uh someone might say what do
you mean just one one you you said that
only one person was killed by his sword
yes elaborate on this I mean see if a
battle is fought and if he is a person
who is too interested to be violent and
kill enemies he should have killed
hundreds of them thousands of them but
then you find that only one person is
killed through his sword that means he
is not our Lord but as Quran testifies
about Prophet Muhammad Allah testifies
in the Quran inia number 21y number
we did not send you but as a mercy to
the entire universe and mercy is that
the people who are innocent should be
given mercy and forgiveness and the
people who are criminals shall be dealt
with Justice so now if some criminal is
being dealt with Justice that is not
being a warlord if American National
Security is defended by attacking the
enemies of America by going for war with
the enemies of America you are not going
to call that Americans are warl thoughts
you're going to say they're defending
their National Security and if it is
done in the just cause then it's a just
War yeah so that is how the history of
Islam goes with Prophet Muhammad s
wasallam his wars were just Wars and
look at the teachings you study poy the
subject in which you study about wars
and you come to understand that there
are different categories of wars and all
the wars that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam fought were just Wars
just Wars yes it wasn't like he was
going picking on people absolutely not
absolutely not I mean this is what the
Ken strong you that historian they
testify Gandhi that's interesting about
Gandhi we're going to go to break but he
after he was finished reading the
biography of prophet Muhammad he was sad
he was he was why would he that's I mean
for the intellectual thinking about he
was known for his nonviolent protest why
would he be sad and why would he be
talking about some praising a violent
warl doesn't make sense doesn't make
sense we're making sense of it all
through truth cuz you're talking you're
getting to know the Muslims make the
human connection we'll be right back
with more God willing don't go anywhere
and another common thing is that it's
religion so this atheist who's out there
yeah you mean Sam hares the likes yeah
they forget about all of the you know
Wars that were done you know
by uh people who are supposed communist
atheists and you can talk about the
millions massives of people who are
killed but what do you say to this
question people ask religions are the
I'm very I'm very surprised that a lot
of educated people who are with good
academic background even they have this
misconception they think that religion
is the main sole source for all the wars
in the world for all the chaos in the
world but as I told you poy is the study
about wars now when you study that the
top five wars in the name of religion
they start the top the top of the line
they say it's the war that was fought in
the Holy Roman Empire fire and that was
that is known in the world today as the
30 years war between
1618 to
1638 so this was the war they say which
was a 30 Years War and this was fought
in the name of religion the second is
the French holy war the third is the
Crusades and the fourth is the Sudan
Civil War the fifth is the Lebanese
Civil War so of the top Wars according
to the experts studying Wars they say in
the name of religion in the world these
are the top five Wars what do I mean by
top five Wars so they say based on the
loss of human lives these are the top
five Wars and the lowest estimate of the
people killed in these top five wars in
the name of religion in human history
they say it is 7 million 7 million
people killed that is the lowest
estimate and the highest estimate is
20.7 million people killed I say man
okay that's fine five wars in the name
of religion the topmost wars and how
many people according to you highest
estimate is 20.7 million okay let's come
to some Wars that were not fought in the
name of
religion to begin with World War I it
was not in the name of religion who
fought it no muslim involved there there
is no Jihad in it there is no Quran
involved there is no slogan called Allah
abbar in World War I how many people
killed according to one estimate about
21 million people according to another
estimate it maybe more than 30 million
people what about World War II the
number of human lives lost in World War
II are recorded in the gness book of
world record how many 50 million human
lives innocent human lives this is minus
the soldiers losing their lives who
fought it Muslims no no Muslim country
was involved in it no Muslim country
initiated it there was no sole interest
of Islam or Jihad in it what about the
Russian Civil War how many Jews were
killed in it
millions of Jews what about the program
which started in Russia in kazakistan a
program is a term a Russian term used
when innocent Jews were killed in riots
what about the kinsha city of Germany
where 91 Jews were killed 7,000
synagogues were burned down can you
imagine that and who was burning them
down that is my question the Muslims
were doing it no you people were doing
it and they were not religious people
the atheists what about the French
Revolution so these were considered
atheists these were absolutely I mean no
religion what about the French
Revolution it was not in the name of
religion it was against religion I mean
so many Christians were persecuted in it
so many churches were pulled down so
many cross signs were pulled down it was
a crime to show a cross sign in France
in time so I'm saying all this was done
by atheists how many people did you kill
not in the name of religion but in the
name of materialistic world
Albania in Albania in Albania you find
that this country for the past about 100
years was ruled by a Communist Regime
and article 37 of Albania it says it's a
country that promotes atheism for a
progressive world and we all know what
happened in Albania how many innocent
lives were killed in Albania but nobody
talks about it this was not in the name
of religion the war in Vietnam did not
happen in the name of religion Vietnam
yeah it was not in the name of religion
the Vietnam War and what about the war
that took place when Hiroshima and
Nagasaki were bombed was it religion
involved no and what happened in Iraq in
2003 we all know if you hear the presid
Trump Administration has selected
Michael Flynn as the National Security
adviser for Mr Trump and Michael Flynn
was the chief of Pentagon for about 2
years and he was into intelligence
services in the Army and on a public
interview platform he says he admits it
was a big blunder big blunder invading
Iraq in 2003 what about nion Nixon is
the person who has interviewed Saddam
hin several times under US Army he was a
former CIA officer and he has come up
with his book now he has written a whole
book and his discussions with Saddam
Hussein he says it was a very serious
error I mean you attack a country you
destroy a country its population you
displace the whole system existing there
you kill millions of people there I'm
asking did America do this in the name
of religion absolutely not so this is
all not done in the name of religion so
don't blame religion for all this stuff
religion very less this is what polymist
study says you look at all these events
and you'll find that it were not Muslims
involved it was not Jihad neither was
any other religion involved these were
done by by those people who did not
actually support religion or believe in
a religion that's a problem yeah what do
you you mentioned Michael Flynn Who was
appointed by uh the new uh yes new
upcoming president what do you think now
with the new president Donald Trump and
this individual who he appointed who is
quoted as saying it's like cancer I've
gone through cancer in my own life okay
so it's like cancer Islam is a cancer
yeah I understand see basically why did
this happen because most of the time
when you hear these people they have
some personal
experiences Flynn he very clearly says
that he has interviewed a lot of
terrorists from Taliban and alqa on this
public media platform there when he was
interviewed on the public media platform
he has been very honest to say that he
has done this and when he was again and
again asked by the anchor do you believe
that Islam is a radical religion then he
says it's it was in a context to say
that if the people who are terrorists
derive a teaching from Islam from the
Holy Scripture so in that sense Islam is
radical so I don't blame Flynn for all
this but definitely a person of his
reputation a person of his caliber
should not have spoken those words
that's not very fair on his part to do
that but then I always feel there is
some laune in our community the Muslim
Community our Representatives they
should have met him they should have
spoken to him discussed with him and as
far as Trump is concerned you see no man
on Earth can do you good or harm you
unless and until the almighty God Allah
doesn't have will that it happens to you
this is what Allah says in Surah Ali
Imran Surah number three aat number 160
Allah says let the Believers put
complete trust in Allah if Allah Wills
to harm you there is none who can
prevent the harm from reaching you if
Allah wants to benefit you there is none
who can stop the benefit from reaching
you so the Believers we put our trust in
almighty God Allah subhana tala and that
is what is the message on the dollar the
US dollar in God we trust and I'm very
sure Trump he already said in his public
speeches that he is a practicing
Christian he believes in Christianity so
a person who believes in Jesus Christ
may peace be upon him who is the Prince
of Peace will not absolutely do anything
which will harm innocent lives as has
been happening in the past few decades
I'm very sure let's have a positive hope
for him and this I'm not saying because
I in America right now or because Trump
has become the president my concept has
always been if there is somebody who is
very anti-islamic in his
propaganda let's go to him let's talk to
him and now that he has become the
president of America as a Muslims
believe we believe that this is because
Allah will so this is the will of Allah
subhana tala now if this is the will of
Allah subhana tala let the Muslims put
all the Trust In Allah let us have good
hopes from Trump and trust me personally
I feel personally I feel that inshallah
by Allah's Will trump will not harm the
Muslim Community but something good is
going to come out in the future
inshallah which was not happening
earlier and what Trump was speaking
either it was something a political
agenda to come into power or maybe he
did not have the proper information
about Islam in the right perspective
once he gets that through the right
people through the right sources the
things will change and I have Good Hope
in the American system for that insh in
the coming days I think we should pray
for Trump what do you think 100% we
should pray Allah subhana tala the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
prayed for Abu jahal
and and we shall also pray for Trump for
every non-muslim we pray alhamdulillah
we pray Allah subhana guide them to your
chosen path mhm I would not say convert
them to Islam I would say oh Allah guide
them to your chosen path oh almighty God
guide them to the chosen PA path and for
me that chosen path is Islam and I'm
very sure I really pray from my bottom
of the heart that oh Allah guide Trum to
The Chosen path of Islam the path that
Jesus followed the path that Moses may
peace be upon Him followed the path that
all prophets since the time of Adam may
peace be upon Him followed till Jesus
Christ may peace be upon him and the
same path that Prophet Muhammad came to
complete the teachings through the Quran
as Allah testifies in Surah maah number
fivey number
three on this day we have completed for
you your religion completed our favors
upon you and chosen for you Islam
meaning the way of peaceful submission
as the way that Allah will accept on day
of judgment so I truly pray for TR for
that we're going to let me get one more
question in and and that just shows you
I mean if if we're people of hate I mean
why all the love now because when you
want the best for someone look you pray
for them so we are people giving his
great advice to the Muslims to pray for
this man that he does the right things
that he's just that he's fair that God
Almighty guides him and that's 100% that
out of the love now uh real quick uh
before we go we're out of time people
see the Middle East and that's where all
the conflict you know is happening and
the Muslim majority countries are upside
down they tribute this you know that's
why Muslims are backward it's Islam is
backward it's violent what would you say
see basically Eddie to begin with uh I
wanted to add one more point before I
concluded the last part of the answer
there is a very major conception that
American population has a majority of
the atheists that's not true the
government system is not an atheist
government system the very statement of
the dollar in God we trust is an
indication that the system itself
believes in a God it is the duty of the
Muslims Living in America to introduce
the true God to them there is no God but
Allah that is the message that we need
to introduce to them we need to
introduce to them that Muhammad sallam
is the messenger to humanity to entire
universe Muhammad he is the messenger
not for me alone to the Muslims alone
but to mankind now when you say Allah
many people they're like what Allah but
then Jesus say Allah isn't it something
in the Christian Christians and uh Jews
who's arabic speaking they word use the
word Allah encyclopedia britanica it
says that the most convenient word that
the Jews and Christians who were Coptic
Jews and Christians Arab Jews and
Christians used for almighty God was
only Allah they had no other option for
them
would this be like the Christian uh so
they can like understand better this is
like the uh the father like for we don't
say that but for them like you know they
have the father son the Holy Ghost this
is the the the god this is Almighty the
almighty they would say the Father the
father say that yeah in the time of
Jesus Christ and Moses may peace be upon
him the father was a common term used by
a lot of people to refer to the almighty
God and it was never in the literal
sense so in that sense we don't say it
because it's been taken as a literal
sense right absolutely Islam Chang it to
from abana it became rabana in so we say
Lord now our lord lord our our Lord so
from our father it became our in Arabic
it is abana our father so Allah made it
r no more abana only R because of all
the confusion Jesus being Lal son God
having children and do you know the
Gallup survey Gallup is a big survey
organization in the United States of
America the Gallup survey for 2016 it
says 81% Americans adhere to religion
one or the other religion 81% meaning
the people in America believe in
religion they are not atheists so it's a
wrong propaganda outside or a wrong
belief outside that there is a vast
majority of people who don't believe in
a religion that's that isn't true that
is what galup survey ISS then coming to
the other point the Gallup made an
extensive survey in 32 Muslim countries
and it came out with a result that
93% of the Muslims in the these 32
Muslim countries they condemned they
rejected
9/11 and they condemned every form of
suicide bombing from Quran there is no
way of supporting suicide bombing it is
the only religious scripture where Allah
says in Surah n Surah number four ayat
number 29 do not kill your own life with
your own hands meaning do not commit
suicide no other religious scripture has
an equivalent statement Allah says you
cannot commit suicide so forget suicide
bombing every form of suicide bombing in
Islam is Haram and what is referred as
salafist Scholars of Saudi Arabia if you
go to the top of the line of the
scholars shik bin Bas who was the Grand
Muti for a very long time you talk about
nasirudin albani you talk about usin
shin in Saudi Arabia the three top most
of the line they strongly condemned
suicide bombing these three Scholars
they have given fatwa on more than 72
pages
saying that Usama Badin and his likes
are terrorists there is no way they have
supported this when it comes to Middle
East problems Robert Pape when he was
studying Robert Pape has written a book
by the name dying to win he's an expert
now anic academic he's a terrorist
expert especially in suicide bombing he
has written a book the dying to win and
it's a central research book on suicide
bombing for agencies to study he says
out of the 3155 completed suicide
bombings from 19 1880 to
2005 more than 90% were
committed only against foreign
occupation as the reason so this is the
root cause now this is the root cause he
says the root cause of suicide bombing
not why these people are doing some that
Islam also condemn so the expert on
suicide bombing says in his study he has
come across that more than 90% of the
suicide bombings were committed not in
the name of religion but as a result
result of foreign occupation on their
territory on their country or on their
land this is what he says and then he
continues to say more than 50% of the
suicide bombings were not committed by
Muslims they were committed by
non-muslim groups like
ltte like the IRA Irish Republican Army
which is a strong Christian background
Army and the PK group of turkey which is
a Socialist Communist group and not a
religious group these are the three most
committing suicide bombings in the world
the Timo tigers are they also a part of
this uh LTT of
course Tigers they are the ones LTT yeah
so they're secular secular group they're
a secular group is a secular group
turkey they're secular and if you find
individually you'll find in LT a lot of
the people who say we are Hindus but I
know Hinduism of course does not promote
violence in this form of suicide bombing
absolutely not so these people they are
not Muslims and this is what what Robert
Pape says and the other
astonishing uh thing that has been found
out on American soil by Gallup survey
and other surveys by the FBI the report
says from since 9911 till date the
Muslims were involved only in 6% of
terrorist attacks mhm 5% by the
Communists six 7% by the Jews 43% and
24% by the Latinos and the white
supremist groups yeah so where did the
Muslim do it mhm even on the American
soil so what's happening in the Middle
East we all know who started the problem
from where did it start when it comes to
Isis Isis I think this is the first time
ever in the recent past you saw all the
Muslim Scholars from all Muslim groups
coming together unanimously condemning
Isis saying they have nothing to do with
Islam and we have been very very vocal
about it when you me a non-muslim on the
road no you should speak about it where
does he want want us to speak put a
earphone in his on his ears and say look
Isis is a terrorist what do you expect
we have been doing it so many scholars
have done it on the mainstream channels
they have done it nobody has ever
supported Isis Isis is a bloody
terrorist organization I said don't call
it an Islamic State call it an insane
state of Iraq and Syria it has nothing
to do with Islam it is open condemnation
given to them so the problem there how
did it happen Michael Flynn again on the
public plat me admits he admits that
isil was not a creation by its own but
it was a result of some other thing he
there are intelligence experts from CIA
and Pentagon who had earlier said that
the Abu prisons in Iraq they worked as
the University of
terrorism it's not the Muslim saying
this so but then why is it that people
don't count on this we say America is
popular in the world for its justice
system people love America and I have
been to America this is my fifth visit
to America the first time I came here I
was called by the US state department I
was apprehensive to come to America but
once I came here meeting the people here
I always tell him in public talks I have
never never met people more kind than
the American population the non-muslim
population of America the common
population they're lovely people the
thing is we need to reach out to them to
give the right message and they need to
understand that Islam is not a threat to
them there are millions of Muslims
Living in America out of the millions
how many may be terrorists not even 100
not even 100 can you imagine that
figure potential terrorists on the basis
of potential terrorists you can't keep
arresting every innocent person and the
conviction rate if you look at the
conviction rate in the UK only only 12%
of the people who are arrested for
terrorism charges were convicted not
more than 12% % meaning in other words
88% were left by the court their cases
were dismissed there were no charges on
them of terrorism just because they were
not involved in it but what about they
getting arrested and being publicized as
terrorists only because you felt they
were a terrorist so you made them a
terrorist in other words now yeah well
we got a lot of things clear clear it up
it's not the Islamic State it's the
insane what' you say the insane state of
irq state and we also uh quoted the
terrorist expert Dr Pape we talked about
if you want to know why these R these
these terrorists are being created
they're not being created by Islam
absolutely you bom people up from 40,000
ft up 10,000 mil away way you kill
people in the weddings they're hanging
out what would you I mean you you you
you're going to end up producing these
mad insane individuals again Islam
condemns it is not condoned by Islam is
condemned but we can see the root cause
unfortunate part Eddie along with this
is that a lot of people have started
think the Muslims because they are
afraid against the system the system
might do something to them therefore
they are condemning terrorism I swear by
Allah I swear by Allah the Muslim
doesn't do that maybe few people do that
way but as a whole this is the book we
read how can we after reading a book
which says you cannot kill an innocent
life even think of killing innocent
people after the Quran the Muslims give
first preference to sah bukari the book
which has the compilation of the
teachings of prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam you read sah Al bukari
volume number four 300 Hadith number 34
to 316 and sah Muslim volume number five
Hadith number
4,547 and
4548 the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said in the battlefield you
will not touch women and
children is this terrorism is this the
statement of a warlord Nah The Prophet
Sall says in sah Muslim volume number
five had number 4541 and 45 42 narrated
by Aisha may Allah be pleased with her
his beloved wife she said the prophet
sallallah alaihi wasallam said never
wish to initiate a war but if the war is
imposed upon you then don't turn your
back the prophet is saying don't
initiate a war is this the statement of
a warlord no I say man you are insane
you are a cynic you are a Critic who
needs some treatment some psychological
treatment all right that's it for this
episode of the dean show doesn't stop
there if you you still have some
questions call US 1 800 662 Islam
remember we're here every week for you
trying to answer those questions those
misconceptions subscribe if you haven't
already I like thank you for being on
the dean show thank you so much thank
you and we start with peace and we am
with peace peace be with you Salam
alikum